hey
oh ok again a trail
the key result of it hey welcome to her
episode of the kira soltanovich show i'm
your host kira soltanovich and usually I
don't have my guests sitting right next
to me as I do the intros and outros but
Greg Fitzsimmons is a union guy and he
just he comes in you know those people
that put like an A rating in front of
restaurants that's what he does he comes
to check spontaneously to see if
podcasts are following the rules in the
podcast host sir Oh roaches in here
they're supposed to do or keeping the
temperature at the correct number he's
in the studio today second time here but
he didn't know that he has a great
podcast that I've been on several times
and you should listen to it I believe
it's called uh fits the Greg fits shut
the fits dog the show that's about dogs
the show dogs it's called fits talk
radio no one usually sits here during
the intro Gregory well you didn't kick
me out all right so it's greg
fitzsimmons is my guest today we talk
about mostly my stuff really I really
kind of hijacked most of it I'm really
going through some stuff and the only
reason I have people here is so that i
can get advice and have a sounding board
and you know i just i have to deal with
this [ __ ] i have to i'm pretty sure i
have to go see a therapist maybe anger
management maybe maybe I probably should
all right we'll see I don't know that
takes money and time and that's two
things I just don't so for now since I
can't afford a therapist i'll just use
comics and greg fitzsimmons has a
twitter account everybody brand new just
opened it so go follow him give him some
followers at Greg F itz show at Greg
Fitz show follow him on Twitter we had a
great conversation of course we get a
little racist it wouldn't be Greg
Fitzsimmons if it
a little racist you know not crazy
racist from a scale from from one to
Donald Trump it was like Courtney Love
blanket pocket all right enjoy my
conversation which is still going on
with Greg Fitzsimmons I was actually
looking at my are we recording I don't
know do you want it we don't have to
record it yes okay you and I well the
thing just go to a coffee shop let's
just tweet the whole thing will go back
and forth hundred and forty hundred and
forty Bam Bam Bam Bam back and forth the
the first podcast tweet know that how
does it doesn't make sense the furnace
be something to it might be a vine a
potty I feel like there's something that
Twitter hasn't exploited yet like you
know there's like asians well Margaret
Cho is definitely tweeting a lot good
okay but um but I feel like there's like
with the debates I really like to live
tweet the debates okay and I feel like
people really love doing that following
a hashtag of that bait feed yes but I
feel like what is missing from Twitter
that would really be interesting that
you could hashtag that people could
follow that you could get because what's
good when people are we doing the
podcast yeah this is oh this is it I
didn't know a lot of people are
professional yep and they say we're
starting a podcast not us that's why
none of us are wearing underwear we are
a different out on our [ __ ] anyway
anyway what is it is the no I'm not
going to circle no no you are the
underwear therefore the [ __ ] or for
the vagina or for the penis because to
be honest my penis doesn't need to be
covered if I could wear like an eye
patch just on my [ __ ] that's all I
need to cover oh my gosh I think you
actually what if there was just an ass
patch yeah huh kind of the opposite of a
thong because the thong doesn't cover
the [ __ ] right so but then how is it
connected to close like it just kind of
suctions on there
because there's something like or else
then there's elastic on the front part
of your junk and you don't want that now
picture picture like a like a smoker's
Patrick a nicotine patch yes okay and
except that it would smell worse than
nicotine or better if you want product
you might as well pina colada or
something fun you know no I just think
the [ __ ] is eventually gonna win the
fight over smell have you been in a cab
in New York the pina colada wins I mean
it's a yeah that's fine it's a good
strong yeah yeah you can tell it's
winning under duress but it's winning
it's winning it's like Jimmy Buffett
showed up and he said we're gonna get
[ __ ] together here yes yeah so there's
yeah I think that's I think you're onto
something I do shark tank Charlotte
shark tank it lets shart tank it this
[ __ ] right it's an ass patch guys who's
my Cuban Mark Cuban mark Karen he's he's
got a dirty [ __ ] yeah of course he
does I mean the thing is is like after I
make a bowel movement I don't want to be
graphic I don't know what good with type
of show you do if you go blue whatever
shade you want I don't see color but do
you have black people on your show ya
who's the last black person had a new
shirt I Barnett 10 minutes ago you're
lying nope he was wearing these
headphones no guys over there wait now
who's ty barnett he's a little
fixer-upper guy comfort nuts ty burrell
pennington anything that's like I'm
supposed ty barnett it's a very funny
comment you know ty he's a very funny
comic yeah I see now I feel bad but you
should probably do know we should know
this is this podcast he does and we
should cut this out of the podcast all
right for your safe so ty barnett was on
yeah I love tie bar I love time yeah hey
so um how to be a grown-up season 3 hey
how about it I could use another eight
hundred fifty dollars each year
I tell you like it I I need another 37
hours of writing to make eight hundred
fifty dollars yeah tell me about it my
manager tried to get me a writing credit
for that show yeah because we wrote me
Rochelle the show and they were like no
no you just well dunno I got our game I
got paid better on that than I thought I
would I just died just signed with a new
manager hmm and as she felt like she was
gonna make her marks we're gonna flex
her muscles for the fits dog great did
she win there and she got me some money
good yeah I can't remember what I made
on that but I will tell you that I got
the same as me maybe but I did have to
for tax purposes get a commission sheet
from my old manager yeah ours was ruined
in a flood we had a flood in our house
you don't even say that because my mom
is in Florida right now on the coast of
West Palm Beach where it's supposed to
hit as a number 4 hurricane and my
[ __ ] mother decided not to leave she
was told to evacuate and she's she's one
of 40 people in her building that decide
yeah we're not gonna go I'm like mom
it's not optional you they won't save
you because they're not going to send
EMTs in to get killed because you were
too obstinate to [ __ ] leave wait but
I heard it was gonna miss Florida it's
gonna be more not as of an hour ago
really no it's going to destroy Florida
[ __ ] and Georgia and South Carolina no
it's this is the biggest hurricane 11
years ok why didn't you fly out and get
your mind just found this out this
morning oh my sister texted me she's
like mom's refusing to leave so I so I
call my mom she's like I'm all set she
said guy put the shutters down and I've
got baby food your mom's gonna be like
lieutenant dan on the roof of her
building is that all you got oh my god
lieutenant dan what's your mom's name
dan
Pat Bad Lieutenant hat well yeah I said
mom first of all unplug everything I go
go fill up the bath tub and go fill up
every can you have with water because
you're gonna run out immediately I said
this isn't like maybe this is hitting
the [ __ ] out of where you are wait is
there nobody on the East Coast that can
go get her the traffic is bumper to a i
looked up if she were to leave now she's
got a friend on the west coast in Tampa
which is about a three-hour drive
normally yeah so I put it into google
maps it would take according to this two
days and 18 hours to get to tampa for
marcia she's [ __ ] she's she missed the
window she was told a day ago to leave
florida i were to leave the east coast
and she didn't but she's got baby food
and she doesn't want to unplug your
computer because she wants to play
hearts while the storm is going on what
is happening with your mom yeah I go did
you what kind of golden did she let any
water she does i get a six pack of salsa
last week salsa yeah does who else lives
in her buildings like an old person
yelling yeah so all the old people
together just gonna 40 as a mesh
together the ganache I know they play
poker they play poker yeah they play
poker for real money my grandmother
played poker she lived to 101 oh [ __ ]
for pennies what ya don't really take it
take it I do I dare you take a unknown
you can put it on to answer it and then
put it on speaker and put it up to the
Mary it's gonna all right hello they
hung up they knew they were on a HOD
cast knew it they knew it I do that
every every call that comes in when I'm
on my podcast yes sirree everyone the
only reason I even have this here is
because I have kids that's only reason
yeah that's the only reason we're here
right actually right we have kids so I
called a hotel yeah I called she lives
in Jupiter Florida and I called all over
town i found one hotel that has a
back-up generator so i made a
reservation for their starting on
saturday so that if she gets if the
powers out because it was out for two
weeks 11 years ago when they had that
big hurricane right right right they
were out of power for two weeks that's
ridiculous what so she has a reservation
how would she even get there I don't
know it's not far you can walk you can
walk in a hundred and fifty morrow we
know this is the aftermath oh okay like
right no I had told I put a rope around
her waist and then to walk to the hilton
sleep oh my god you know people always
Oh California earthquakes yeah
earthquakes can be [ __ ] scary but
I've only been in one not a hurricane a
tornado yeah I could I don't know what
the difference is by no one's now a
tornado is a spinning the space of air
okay well then maybe I was in a
hurricane but this was Michigan Domitian
the Michigan doesn't get hurricanes they
get tornado so I think they get
tornadoes one one time and that was
enough closer to get to you I was in a
tornado taint right I was there's a part
of like when you drive I was driving
from Chicago I landed in chicago had a
gig a college in Central Michigan and I
was listening to the radio and they
basically said like there was one in
ahead of me and one behind me so there
was like oh wow [ __ ] in front of me
and I was headed to her I mean it was
and then and then I was stuck and then I
called my husband who's also from
California so the two of us we don't
know [ __ ] yeah he told me go drive into
a ditch hahaha as we told me do what am
I gonna drink I don't know it sounds
like a Nancy Grace kg wikipedia'd what
do you do in a tornado and he's like I'm
gonna Wikipedia right now and he'd said
drive into a ditch and I go but no other
cars on the freeway or doing that I'm
watching all these cars and you're gonna
get covered over yeah you're in the
ditch you're gonna get covered with dirt
and debris Hey well well from California
what do you want from I want you gone I
think so too try froze why would he send
me to Stanford and Sons in kansas city
all right and right that [ __ ] Club
he's sending you see I booked you I got
a jolly books you like the worst
the country um side splitters called oh
okay oh they're in Florida Karen Tampa
um no he said I go that no other car I'm
looking all these cars in front me they
all have Michigan plates I'm sure to
follow what they're doing yeah and we
are all driving you know two miles an
hour yeah two miles an hour and we're
just like just they kept driving so I
kept driving yeah it's frightening it
was so scary that is scary because if
one of those twisters hits you you're
your dad you're just [ __ ] dead and
then you don't make that college money
but I'm yeah that money was good i
missed that money no when i was first
coming up in comedy I was uh you know
I've been doing it for six seven years
enough where I could go and do schlock
an hour together for a bunch of kids in
a cafeteria yeah and I mean I was making
no money I was going after seven hundred
bucks pop 800 bucks sometimes on a
really good one 900 bucks but my agent
would string together you know 12
schools in 10 days because I do nooner
at one and a night time at another and
I'd come home with like you know ten
grand yeah I was pretty sweet when I
beautiful yeah my husband thinks I did a
bait and switch on him because when he
and I met I had just booked like 30
colleges oh so he's like I'm dating this
chick was a comic she's you know making
good money and then I was also in a TV
show at the time and then I was also
doing like you know now two kids later
yeah nobody wants why are you talking
bagging titties yeah sagi sagi can we
feel so bad for these my body just looks
like dirty laundry yeah and the coloring
to is probably all [ __ ] up right then
the apples are stretched and yeah
they're looking five dollars going on
five different color schemes right you
know like when you decide on paint for
your wall so you put like five different
yeah Oh green but there are five
different greens yeah and the plan is to
paint over them but then you run out of
money right and now you've got tits that
are five different knowledge mmhmm yeah
I just found out today our good friend
breast implants and I never knew it I
just always thought she had a really
great tit you mean our mutual good
friend are you and your family's good
friend now me and my fav hot okay so not
someone I know no no I can introduce you
to her I would love it she's gonna be at
that comedy benefit I'm gonna do your
kids comedy it's not your can introduce
you to 10 women that night you have to
guess which one has real tits and if you
do the fake tits and if you do I'm gonna
give you one hundred dollars okay I want
to be blindfolded oh and I want there to
be like game show ticking clock in the
background let's make it fun and it
makes a bunch of noise and it works man
hand me the one to look at a game show
where you know it's like handing me the
bills all crisp in my hand and they're
gonna be confused and I had no idea
what's going on no idea just random game
show lights some bells and whistles hey
what if at the end though she goes
you're playing the tip came again hahaha
happens at every kid's benefit show I go
to tip game yeah um I find fake boobs
very frightening yeah really um almost
like you know when a dog has been bred
that two breeds it should not happen
right and you look at your like I know
that I should like you right now I know
that you're still cute like look how
funny and interesting you are it's a
Burmese Mountain Dog in a shih tzu shift
it's always a [ __ ] it's always a [ __ ]
two niches give up the [ __ ] they do
yeah they put the dog in doggy style but
you're tight like I have this neighbor
that walks their dog and I'm just like I
know your dog is supposed to be cute but
it's [ __ ] me up right now yeah the
skull is too big to the head is staring
at it like what I can't pinpoint what I
don't like about and if it's a good hey
breeze like that because the nostrils
aren't deep enough for the head exactly
yeah it's all [ __ ] up but then as a
man this is when you say I'd still do
him oh absolutely absolutely yeah yeah
yeah what's it like I sometimes ask my
husband what is it like what kind of
burden is it to have a penis it depends
like I've never been big on grooming I
literally
I don't mean grooming I mean just having
it all the time it's in your pants yeah
it's a burden it's a burden a little bit
right it is because you know I think you
always want to feel like at any given
moment if your [ __ ] were to come out it
would be fluffed never see trial you
would be like right now if I pulled down
its I guess I don't know if little cold
and I can feel it's it's not as big as
it would be sure and I feel like you're
always insecure when your penis isn't
like if you're if you have an erection
you're extremely excuse the pun but
you're cocky your network comes from
right right right your [ __ ] sure you're
really powerful yeah and then there's
times we're like you know we went to a
river me and my friends we went hiking
we all got naked and jumped in the water
not all of us revis jumped in three
didn't and the three that didn't jump in
made fun of the three that did because
it was ice cold mountain water and our
penises shrunk into like a baby's fist
which is actually the only thing you
should have near your penis when you
jump in cold water if a baby gives you a
hand job it looks much bigger bigger
yeah so um I think that the size of your
penis at any given time it direct
inversely correlates to your self-esteem
interesting and so that's a hard thing
to deal with all day every day all day
the reason I'm concerned about is
because and I know I've talked about
this a million times Erin can vouch for
it my five-year-old is constantly
touching it yeah and humping stuff right
did your kid do that no even boy and a
girl no they weren't my kids were not
very genital real they weren't very
gently fixated what did I do during
pregnancy lumen he is obsessed he's just
it's just a peanut and that's just what
it is and i asked him sometimes very
casually hey is everything okay with
your penis just like super cache like
hey hey hey this hot out lately isn't it
yeah they do the way has a it's kind of
your dick do you want to eat a soup look
just throw it away like a throwaway
lawyer right and he's like yeah
everything's fine i go okay cuz you just
I you know do you need daddy to go look
at it
like no I go okay cuz you're breaking it
you're gonna break it you're gonna break
it off and you're 5 and you're gonna
want oh you mean it's erect and he's
playing with it both it's all the time
Wow does he fizzy circumcised yeah why'd
you circumcise him okay we're gonna go
down that route is some kind of an
animal yeah I did it with my teeth I did
it so he knows like was in charge mommy
mommy loves you like like a cigar like
we smoke a cigar picked a little force
get out of my teeth for like an hour
later people look at you get a little
some in your oh that's just uh oh that's
just circumcision better how about now
it's like broccoli um great sounds for
podcasts um your son is not he's not
okay that's fine I added me to get
worked up about it I would love to get
worked up about I wanted I failed it
genital mutilation is something that we
should stop back in the 1970s look yeah
I agree I was on the fence hmm that's
how we did it we did on a fence we just
see is one of those really sharp ends at
the other round ones at koya no I was on
the fence and actually had some a
dickwad I don't know if you're still
listening um if you are don't because
this podcast is not for you then but he
or she because they they sent me some
facebook message from like a fake
facebook account saying like don't talk
about the circumcision story anymore you
made a bad choice that was not the right
thing to do and then I tried to reply
and it was like a fake fake facebook
page yeah it no was wait yeah yeah so
there was no way to reply and I wanted
to reply and just say hey I'm sorry you
feel this way if you don't like it don't
listen that's what's so interesting is
the reason we do podcasts is so that we
can say whatever everyone there's no one
telling us there's no network there's no
language please watch your language Oh
nobody is telling you how to produce
your podcast and yet people still feel
they can write in like it's Johnny
Carson yeah you know when they would get
like bags full of mail yeah because
that's the only way you could tell
Johnny Carson didn't like his sketch and
Johnny read that mail yeah I mean you
were you read about like you know
Elizabeth Taylor used to sit around
dressed up in a gown with our hair done
and sit with like a quill pen yeah and
reply to each piece of it what I don't
leer heed my [ __ ] tweets yeah people
tweet me yeah but that's that was the
only form of communication there's just
too much communication y'all too much
access and so now people are just like
oh [ __ ] it you know send sense a message
to my manager he's listed on my you know
my website or whatever yeah but back
then that was just like somehow they got
an address you know metro-goldwyn-mayer
you know to me like yeah right mm they
sent it to the studios and um but
anyways a circumcision so I have gotten
a lot of [ __ ] hmm regarding circuses so
did your husband feel like it was
something he wanted to do we were both
we both didn't know we both were like
why are what do you think I looked it if
I could go back now maybe we wouldn't
but I honestly don't think it's going to
I don't think it's gonna scar him and I
don't think that it's a time where
enough people aren't circumcised where
he's going to stand out I think we're in
a middle period but it's going that
direction where less boys are getting
circumcised in 20-30 years you'll stand
out if you're circumcised that's like
two shanks the first is full disclosure
okay we were completely on the fence
about doing it and then mice my wife had
a c-section and we had seen enough blood
and scissors and stitches and we went
[ __ ] it okay I've made the decision for
us and our GP was kind of like or done
GP what's the [ __ ] doctor called PP is
a doctor ya [ __ ] doctor yep and she
actually had a car as so into it that it
she put pubic hair on it and wrote [ __ ]
doctor on the Sun I like that and as I
put made the bumper pink with like
brownish edges uh-huh okay
and so we only didn't do it because it
was like a last minute thing but I'm so
glad we didn't because I just feel like
you know and again this isn't judgmental
of you right but but no but I'm just
glad because it's like one less thing to
to you know it's something that I can
feel as somebody lives on the westside
of LA I've got my Prius my son's not
circumcised he's intact and my wife was
faked it so it's great your wife does
not have an act it's real tips but
they're good they're amazing I've seen
him have you I went to your house to do
the podcast the first time you looked at
her tits of course they're big why
wouldn't you the 34 double D's come on
yep they were DS then she breastfed
kicked it up to a double D stayed there
swear to Christ really a nice nipples
amazing yeah good for her you lucked out
I feel good about it yeah you should
feel good about your choice yes cuz
lucky it's a crapshoot get married
everyone's young and tight yep
everywhere yeah you know I'm sure your
nuts are not where they used to be no I
know means it's almost like a nice jump
in a mountain lake kind of helps them
yeah right a little younger too right
yeah who I haven't been so close to the
thigh in a low it's amazing this total
clearance my thighs are just walking now
you're thinking about breast implants a
little bit no I would never do that why
not ah I don't know what about a what do
you call it a lift a lift ya nah heard
those are really painful yeah I think
they're fine in the right brassiere it's
fine right I would do a nose job before
I did implants a nose job yeah that's
wrong with your nose Judaism oh stop
come on you see you think I should stay
intact yes shouldn't take a look
circumcision now that's so funny I
wouldn't think about that with you with
your nose I mean I wouldn't obviously
right I would have a long time ago if I
ever really was serious about it but
what about your voice throw the trough
you okay
you Oh Fitz I think about you every
morning you do think about you every let
me guess why morning you have a finished
yet oh yeah the coffee mug I have the
copy Manya I masturbate into a coffee
mug be do with your coffee we can you
feel it cuz you didn't used to be able
to fill it um I felt it's too I feel it
too much yeah so you need a oh I'm
talking about coffee actually um we have
one of those you know like a Keurig
e-type tassimo thing yeah pods and it's
just like I fill it up and then I put my
cream in it is just right there right
it's I got actually slurp it from the
counter a little bit sometimes you
slurping the fits dogleg every morning I
slurp your mug in the morning I think
I've actually tweeted you saying it's a
to Fitz dog day yes yeah an outside love
was a three because I have a
one-year-old yeah um we have like five
different subjects that we were talking
about but just to go back to the penis
yes circumcision right just to finish up
with that I have only been with one guy
that was uncircumcised yeah and I'm just
and this is not why we circumsized our
son but it was weird that's all I'm
gonna say that's it was weird of the
music cheese everything just we're just
real there was weirdness odor just a
like a lot like a list I could do a list
of just weird stuff no kidding so
premature ejaculator ah I don't think
maybe cuz i think part of ramen because
your shield if she the crown is more
sensitive maybe I don't know I've talked
about before I'll just tell you the
story the backstory people who are sick
of this sorry but that just happens on
podcasts yeah right to her on facebook
yeah there you go write to me on
linkedin and read those um I don't know
why linkedin exists but ok either I
here's the story i'll make it really
quick my nephew born in the Soviet Union
like I was they don't circumcise their
I'm giving you like the just bullet
points so when he immigrated here to the
states at twelve thirteen he
have a Bar Mitzvah you have to get
circumsized so at 12 / almost 13 he got
circumsized to have his Bar Mitzvah yeah
which at that point I would have been
like guess I'm not Jewish anymore yeah
but that was his choice yeah so I'm 36
weeks pregnant about to have a kid and I
call him and I go look I gotta talk to
you about your penis he's like sure now
he's 25 yeah you know um and and he's
like sure what you want to know and I go
we don't know if we're gonna circumcise
you're the only person i know that's had
it both ways so and at 13 i think you
know what it does you know what I mean
and he said look I prefer it's
circumcised that's all that was it I was
how he made the choice yeah that was a
but I don't think it's a good or I don't
think it matters if you're not I don't
think it matters if you do i think if
you that's just it's a hard thing for
people to grasp who are so pro keeping
boys intact and I get it and I
understand why and again if we had
another boy we probably wouldn't i
should just commit suicide because
because i don't feel you waited too long
for the podcast you know what it is well
actually this is the reason i came on i
want to give you some big ratings cuz
you always thinking what to title your
podcast yeah Greg Fitzsimmons kills
himself that I might have to get what
kind of font would i use i would go Cory
yes yes comic sans Comic Sans is about
because I don't like people that feel
that strongly about intact or where yeah
I don't feel it certainly about anything
and I spent my life trying to pick
middle positions because I don't have
the energy to care and ive one ive one
and so it's lost oh now i don't care
about anything about anything anymore
but isn't that wonderful it's supposed
to be that was the goal my goal was to
become zen-like and not to react to
things but then you realize as comedians
you're supposed to be bill burr yeah
you're supposed to get crazy because a
Kardashian did whatever
but I think on stage you still care i
tol an act that's but that's that's
supposed to be an act yeah that's the no
you just [ __ ] figured out life yeah
your life your day-to-day breathing
inhale exhale you just choose them at
hey everything's all right it's ok yeah
and then when you're at work you're
passionate whatever your job is you're a
plumber you're like I'm bout to [ __ ]
plunge the finest toilet yeah I'm gonna
go we're gonna go down for the brown
yeah who wants a plunger that's like um
I guess we'll see if it works if not oh
well no you want someone passionate
about cleaning your sink if it's clogged
and then they come home and then they're
like chill yeah that's actually it's
good and the insult cuz I should have
stayed on my tack of shaming you about
the circumcision because that was the
comedic that choice that would have been
fruitful right but then I backed off it
and I told you full disclosure you know
we had to decide either right and then
and then where do you go from there
where do we go well you circumcise your
daughter though well she's black oh yeah
okay I don't know why that well African
women have it done to them stuff like we
adopted her please send your letters
forget to MGM Studios um oh my thing um
so okay just to go back real quick yeah
bill burr bill burr has a very that
didn't sound like a slam of bill burr no
no I just mean that was action it that
guy can get passionate about things yes
like I wouldn't even thought twice about
and then I go yeah right I [ __ ] agree
with him actually that's where his
genius comes yeah but he has a bit that
in my heart and actually we're this is
his podcasts to do by the way oh right
yeah he has a bit about moms having such
a tough job yeah and it's a genius
brilliant bit saying that they don't
have a tough job well he's saying like
really really I was a roofer in the
middle I'm [ __ ] up his joke and I'm
so sorry but basically it's and I'm sure
you've heard it I was a roofer in the
middle of July as a pail kid you know
sitting in the Sun that's a rough job
and talking about how like oh you put a
lion king
DVD in today oh what a tough job you
have but I want to do a counter to that
if I if I wanted to I don't want to
because I don't want to go up against
baller because yeah but my counter to it
is yeah to be a good parent is a tough
job that's a shitty parent that you just
described will you put a video in yeah
and go all right kids sit down let's go
watch Oprah I'm gonna watch my stories
now that's a shitty parent and you're
right that is it's easy to be a shitty
parent yeah but I my kid I'm exhausted
yesterday I was so [ __ ] tired of all
the [ __ ] I was doing all this stuff I
had to do this I had to finish a script
I had it and my kid was like mommy play
with me and I looked at him and I was
like okay and I got down on all I was
wrong with him and we played some
[ __ ] game that he made up which by
the way he made it up so that he wins
every ran yeah that's [ __ ] Conte but
I'm like I don't like trying to explain
to him cuz he's now five almost six
right I go dude just so you know you
can't change the years in the middle six
little old yeah it's a little old for
like just making up the rules yeah um
but he's like no no here's here's the
game and he made up this game yeah with
these pebbles but I gotta hand it to him
he's being creative and he's making up a
game so I'm like all right I'll play
with you but [ __ ] and I want some rules
down in yes yeah I want them I got to I
got a script it could be paying for your
college education it's not getting done
but I want to do a rebuttal to bill burr
but I'm also scared of bill burr all
right have you had him on your show no
he doesn't have kids oh you have to have
kids to come on the show do you [ __ ]
know you've been on the show before yeah
I know you excluded people that didn't
have I exclude and if you have if you've
ever worn a helmet and if you're in tact
two guys with you I'm letting this slide
are intact I am intact you're not
circumcised circumcised oh I like how
you said it like I'm not a crazy person
well
Shin everybody got circumcised no I mean
except Allah I think that Latino kids
didn't get circumcised maybe Cubans
probably Cubans right yeah yeah you see
Jose yes I was that human you're going
through your rolodex of penises um
what's happening with your kids talk to
me about your kids because they were
older now my son turned 16 this week and
he got his a learner's permit and within
48 hours he had smashed the car not
smashing but he he knocked the bumper
off pulling out of the driveway come on
my wife's fault I was on the road well
[ __ ] I drivers well no no she was in the
street moving her car so that he could
pull out my car and drive it but our
driveway is kind of narrow and it has a
gate and he backed out cut the wheel
pulled the bumper off [ __ ] 40 and I did
can't get mad at him that's her fault
[ __ ] her fault that's a [ __ ] 9
difficulty move backing out of this
turning driveway with the come on oh
come on that's her fault was did he seem
deflated after that or no you don't give
a [ __ ] ok he could care less that's what
pissed me off I came home and I expected
as Mia culpa yeah at least some
addressing of it ya know instead like we
went to get in the car and and I had at
a i taked it up my [ __ ] Prius is
taped together like I'm some kind of a
Cambodian taxi driver and he walks up
and he goes oh yeah oh yeah just that's
it oh my god i would have been groveling
at my parents oh cuz i smashed my
parents car not terrible but i did I
[ __ ] it up a little bit the grill in
front yeah you're a rear ended somebody
my sister her first time driving with
her license she got her license and
she's driving alone down Broadway in
tarrytown cop opens up his car door
sister takes it off takes it off the car
we my mom and with his big capris
classics yes giant four-door v8's it
didn't even shoot her foot Davy we hit
the [ __ ] breaks that did and the cop
apologize he goes my fault totally my
fault oh my god yeah different times
different times no body cameras back
then what did your parents do there you
know we got in so many accidents my
brother totaled a car my sister i don't
know if i should say this on the air but
uh murdered somebody she took the car
out one night she was 16 she was dating
a guy who lived it you know the next
town over and she took the car one night
after my parents went to sleep to drive
him home dropped him off and then fell
asleep at the wheel and drove through
somebody's yard and hit a tree in their
yard and told the car what and then I
took the car my sister came with a boss
when I was in college to visit brought
the car I was driving it and a guy ran a
red light I might have had a cocktail
and he hit me and then I hit another car
and the car was completely totaled
impounded I don't think you your family
should be allowed to do no I think if
you have your last name is Fitzsimmons
at the DNA that you shopping they don't
know yeah eyes yeah on we've seen your
work ya know how everybody in your
family hang the car my brother me and
and then fender benders tons of fender
benders she yeah so um you know it's
gonna happen and somebody said that to
me with how old is your oldest five and
yeah yeah so you'll see they want to
once he gets the license in their life
everyone's like it's going to happen so
just accept in advance right that the
car will get [ __ ] up and then you
won't freak out as much yeah i mean i
have so many other things that I'm
worried about before a driver's license
riding with the trauma from circumcision
yeah
they have therapy for that I'm sure they
do look I saved if he wants to put it
back on later in his life it's up to him
it's his choice in a condom wrapper I
love how people are like how could you
make a choice like that for him hmm I
made every choice I made the choice to
have him yeah II need oj right to send
him to school right I mean I'm making
every choice for you why is that choice
a special choice yeah I mean I know it's
very polarizing and I get it I get it
and I honestly if people want to hate my
son's penis because of that great the
less people that like it that's a chair
for me that's true until he's old enough
any signs of homosexuality what is a
sign of homosexuality you don't like
wearing girls clothes or um you know I
want to remodel your house no no I mean
I wouldn't care if there were though
that's what I was gonna ask you yeah
follow-up question no no I am never ever
hesitated if he wanted to buy something
that stared typically people will be
like oh you let him buy a pink blah blah
blah I'm I fall for i play with dolls
whatever you want to do whatever that
can backfire why if you if you don't let
if you say you can't have a pink right
whatever I think then like I used to
wear my mom's heels yeah and you know
and then a couple years ago I just said
I'm I'm gonna give you your own shoes
back you're gonna need these to run
right to the hilton down the street oh
my god she's such an idiot no I feel bad
that's an old lady by herself in a storm
and you're sitting your podcasting what
am I you have this thing and in your
head that I'm supposed to be flying to
Florida right now I'm yes you know how
long it would take me to get from the
airport to her house assuming the
flights are lent the flights aren't
landing they vary can't like the flights
looks like you gotta fly to Houston and
dry
from there I don't know however well
believe me I am planning on flying down
there sunday or monday if it's if it's
really bad I'll fly down there sunday or
monday yeah and help her you know get
her books back up on the shelf or
whatever I totally get oh I said get
your passport out I said go to an ATM
machine texting her I every time I think
of another suggestion I keep texting
it's who we r all morning and says she
word right thank you in a smiley face
ignored the last seven texts like okay
you're freaking me out now it's like
yeah I should be freaking you out since
the news didn't and the governor didn't
when he told you to [ __ ] leave the
governor is a really freaky governor
though he is I don't know if I'd trust
anything that [ __ ] our says I know
what is I'm going to be in Florida next
week is it still gonna be there oh yeah
okay what club I'm doing like three
different things really yeah i'm doing
like a one night in boca and then two
nights down in a casino like in fort
lauderdale and then another gig in Miami
was booking you I booked me but did you
get one date in Florida then go after
other dates in Florida I got like two
offered and another one came and really
I gotta hustle interesting I'm not the
fits dog look the fits dog would love to
be going out of Florida and patching
together for different nights and not
flying back and forth yeah I I'm all for
one-nighters though I loved one night oh
my god my favorite thing fly out early
morning yeah get there do the gig next
morning come home boom I love it but I
I'm gonna be there for almost a week
yeah and I'm bringing my one year old
you are I gotta do you breastfeeding
know what why do you have to bring them
her her cuz I can't put that on my
mother-in-law yeah two kids all right
you know what I mean it's too much yes
too much it just I can't it's a lot I
can barely handle two kids yeah now we
sure your son is he in preschool still
occur in a garden no he's in
kindergarten now yeah he's in
kindergarten so he's got a full day out
not not that full but yes yeah yeah so
my mother lock and handle
one kid uh-huh and you know she'll do it
bill burr style right I told her I go
look if he wants to watch like PBS kids
to make your life easy uh-huh I don't
care it's not a that's not a normal
thing I'm one of those hippie moms yeah
where I try to really limit really yes
going to good good that's like a treat
yeah that's like you can earn you know I
don't know did you let your kids just
put him in front of the TV all the time
I think it was DVDs not a lot of them
but no definitely like a DVD a day you
know like every day you know like a like
a booty call Teletubbies or some [ __ ]
for like an hour well now this is my
version of penis shaming you you think
that's excessive an hour of TV a day for
a child I mean how old you know Brandon
three weeks [ __ ] she put headphones on
them give an iPad get him real close uh
I don't know I i vacillate yeah right
between look if I had to get [ __ ] done
then this is gonna calm you down fine
yeah but then I also go for like a week
without no no screen time really yeah
cuz i get like on this weird thing where
it's like it's [ __ ] you up yeah i'm a
weird neurotic jew kids watch so much
[ __ ] TV now well because they're
teenagers yeah so well with a teenage
you can't just go all right let's play a
board game or let's go ride our bikes
they're just like canned or like [ __ ]
you teenager I don't do [ __ ] with you
anymore really not really your kids do
so i can tell your kids do stuff with
you because your garage is full of do
stuff right junk I think thing not junk
in a bad way no leg going well uh I mean
like I take my son to soccer practice
two or three days a week and that's
that's down in El Segundo so I drive
them down I stay down yeah and so we
spent a lot of time together like listen
to each other's music cuz that's like a
half hour each way and and I watch his
games and you know there's that that's
like our quality time and then with my
daughter you know we just hang we'll
just hang and talk you know we she's a
deep thinker she says deep [ __ ] yeah and
and she'll ask me questions that I have
to really think about a lot
and then she surfs I'll go down to the
ocean with her and watch her surf what
kind of stuff does she ask you um like
when Jesus died did he go to his body
really go to heaven or was that just a
spirit that went up to heaven and I say
well it's the Transfiguration so it with
him it was physically his body ascended
but with us it's just our souls and then
she said but then what happens to your
body and I say well just goes into the
earth and she said but then where is
heaven like [ __ ] where I'm going like uh
oh let me pick up Wikipedia real quick
hey let's put a DVD in the Ten
Commandments here's Teletubbies yeah
yeah so you know oh my god I can't
handle that that's why you'll stop
talking to them no no I talked him and
my daughter watches a lot of [ __ ] TV
my son is busy with work and he's a jock
so he doesn't watch as much but she's
got she's got too much time on our hands
but she I remember talking to you or did
I I listen to your podcast yeah I'm have
you saying something about um maybe I'm
mixing up details but I remember I heard
that she surfs and then something else
oh no your son you oh and we were on how
to be a grown up your son was going to
Europe to play soccer that's what it was
to Spain to Spain yeah he's like a
soccer he was the captain of the US team
went to Spain yeah I was an
international tournament and then he was
the only freshman on his a on his a
varsity team at his high school and he's
really good but watch is it watches
every professional game plays fifa
soccer dribbles the ball around the
house like he's obsessed which I don't
get cuz I wasn't a jock at all i was i
was a freshman on the varsity hockey
team no i'm sorry i was a senior Oh on
the JV hockey team which i think is
illegal I don't think you're allowed to
have a kid that old on the JV team and
you were
fifth-year senior you were like I was a
ten year senior I was like I we I went
to a really rough high school yeah so we
had some dirt Glendale know in San
Francisco yeah we had some
twenty-year-old seniors yeah our
football team rock yeah I mean they had
like mustaches kids in their own and
yeah yeah it was we have some good
athletes um so what so what is she why
does she watch so much TV and why do you
allow it you can still tell her job
right now there's just not a lot of
homework you know when you're in the
eighth grade is just not a big homework
here and you know if I'm on the road is
nothing I can do and my wife is driving
my son around and she's home and she
starts watching like she's watching
grey's anatomy now she's watched like
seven seasons of grey's anatomy that's
not the worst she's seen the office like
every every episode of every season of
the office again not the worst it's it's
like you know keeping up with the
kardashians no she doesn't watch crap
like okay well then that's different i
know but it does bum me out though the
amount that she watches and I feel like
I wish I could I wish we had like a
craft table yeah and you know we had
like foreign instruments that she could
record them to use GarageBand and I wish
she gave a [ __ ] about things like that
yeah but she just but she's so well
adjusted in such a smart deep and she
gets A's is I got kind of go like all
right what am I gonna bust your balls
watch the [ __ ] Grey's Anatomy right
now do you ever say things like why
can't you be more like your brother I
think I would probably say why can't you
be like your sister really yeah Wow cuz
she'll like make dinner for us Oh she'll
like clean the house she'll she goes in
babysits and makes money like she's
she's a worker my parents always pitted
me against other kids oh yeah not my
brother money he they always bet on the
other kid yeah um not my brother cuz he
was so much older yeah but like other
kids like if I didn't practice piano my
parents my mom especially be like well
you know Grisha Feinstein's he plays van
good everyday practice not like you you
miss he ever you miss I miss practice
you know you you don't go you make fun
oh I'm going to make fun of piano Grisha
Feinstein he plays very beautiful very
nice I'd like wow them go [ __ ] live
with him I would get so pissed right
that my parents would do that my mom
would do that piano lessons seemed to be
like a really scarring bang for kids I'm
scarred I don't even know how to play
one song I played for eight years yeah
yelling eight to sixteen and one day I
was sitting so I went to a school of the
arts high school I was sitting in a room
like we had these practice rooms we just
sit by yourself and you know me now and
as a comic now I think like that was
pure hell right solitary confinement
that was like a jail sentence for me
because I need people I need I need an
audience I need to to speak yeah and
when you're just like sitting in a
practice rehearsal room we had these
little rooms like like cells yeah like
he was like a prison and just sit there
you practice and you practice in one day
six years old junior in high school I
just stood up like Forrest Gump you know
that moment where he's like I'm just
gonna start to run I just like stood up
close the piano the keyboard you know I
just walked out I was like I'm done
really done I don't want to look at it I
don't want to see it I don't want to
think about piano and you ever hold 16
from eight to 16 i played and you can't
play a song not one not one not one and
I think it's all psychological Wow of
course it is that's def crazy yeah and
you were a decent pianist decent good
enough to get into a performing arts
school I got in on cello and theatre but
I played piano as well but I got in on
cello you still play cello No
oh my god I sound like someone was
fingering a cat you should not tell kids
they can do anything you should not
encourage kids to let's encourage
children to but no not every kid do you
even own a cello no do you have a piano
in your house in my dad's house still my
dad's cause like when you're going to
pick up your piano yeah i go i'll pick
it up to go drop it off somewhere for
you're not gonna i wish we had one in
the house I'll be honest with you that
would be kind of awesome but it's such a
pain to I'd rather just buy one or get
one the garage sale then go to San
Francisco pack it on a truck drive it
now you think you would start playing it
again i would i would even though i
probably should see a therapist before i
do well you'll probably it'll probably
all get unlocked i mean have you sat at
a piano in the last few years sure and
as a fun little like oh here's what i
remember yeah but I have so much trauma
from it from your parents pushing you so
hard yeah I was hit severely if I didn't
practice no yeah they beat you a feud
impressed yes oh Jesus yeah one of my
biggest beatings was from directly from
not practicing that's why I have to
constantly like catch myself before I
get angry with my five-year-old because
I would never do that to him but I have
to it's like being an alcoholic and it's
just every day you have to say I'm not
gonna drink today yeah I'm not going to
drink today can I get through today
without hitting my kid that's what you
have to think I mean it's a sad reality
of me and it sounds worse than it is cuz
it sounds like I constantly want to hit
him I don't I absolutely adore my kids
no but the default setting is to hit the
default setting is that's what I was
taught yeah it was every day and it was
not every day okay now I'm exaggerating
no no delete delete delete it wasn't
every day but it was looming hmm so like
you excited are you on my podcast we
talked about you were hit as well um
it's not like
I constantly every day I came home and
was like oh here's my daily beating but
when you are hit as a kid it's the
potential is there if the frequency
doesn't matter it matters that it could
happen right and you know it could
happen and so my fear is I need to
constantly check where I'm at on a daily
basis it's exhausting but I constantly
like okay am I am i sending off some
sort of crazy vibe to him right now
because I don't want to be crazy parent
yeah but unfortunately and I feel like
it's going to get better once the 41
year old is a little bit older but I'm
you know the only time that I had had
the compulsion to hit which I never did
but when I felt that I was in danger of
it I think ended by about age four I
think it's really when they're so young
and [ __ ] spazzy and yeah and aunt
cyan't that's when you really feel like
because you can always reason with an
older kid and take away things from them
bribe them near this tricks right but
when they're that young there's no
tricks they are in the moment and they
are a rageful Tasmanian devil yeah and
there's nothing you can do except what
you imagine is violence will stop this
right so I sometimes raise my voice and
then I hate myself I hate myself you're
allowed to raise your voice yes but I'd
it just it doesn't matter it's again
it's like saying I'm an alcoholic but I
mean have some robitussin ya do ya I me
like have some nyquil yeah I can't cuz
even nyquil that little bit you don't I
mean well yes and no I also think that
khalix I can't but I also think that
emotionally you have to be able to vent
on some level like and I think that it's
healthy for your kids to see mommy and
daddy are human and that they can get
mad and that right some of you some of
their actions can trigger that behavior
for mommy and daddy which you don't like
you know and day and mommy and daddy
don't like so you
walk the line so he was kicking my chair
the other day we were driving and he was
asking about something I hope you
punched the [ __ ] and I said we're gonna
be home in five minutes he wanted to
change his shirt yeah I said it was a
hot I go let me turn the AC on somewhere
in the car no I need to change my shirt
I go dude I talked to him like he's you
like I talked to my keys an adult I go
did you're being a little ridiculous
okay I'm not gonna pull the car over
unbuckle you from your 13 point harness
child harnesses unwrap you from the
bubble wrap you know whatever you know
it's like take off your helmet gonna for
you to change your t-shirt we're going
from an air-conditioned car into our dry
into our garage into an air conditioned
house yeah you'll be okay but because
he's five it's one track minds he's
making my chair kick in my chair I want
I want I want so I just and I'm just
ashamed to even say this but I at the at
the next red light I just did one of
these I go enough I did one of those
yeah and I [ __ ] hated myself Phil I
don't know for a second for the
slightest nanosecond yeah for like the
slightest it feels and then it feels
terrible but the terrible feels a
hundred times more terrible than that
nanosecond of like cuz he shut out cuz
he shut up and stop kicking so he did
what I wanted but and it wasn't violent
it was just me like hmm but I felt awful
dude why did you feel like you scarred
him yeah yes yeah I'm shaking his head
Aaron is shaken at what Aaron chime in
go ahead child list head shaker that's
all my my parents rarely you know they
spanked only had two but yeah my dad
just had this booming voice and that's
all it frightened me and that's fault
okay you need my correction it's like
nature that's what animals do they go I
feel like Caesar shuts his Nick not
Cesar Chavez Cesar Millan you know where
he trains the dog but good yeah and it
kind of like corrects their behavior
yeah right does this like sound that you
know the less you yell
the less you need to yell so I just
think it's a it's a question of
amplification you know if you if you're
really a mild-mannered person right and
you go stop that's a lot but if you're
you're a loud person to begin with I a
so you need to yell a little bit louder
than she talking to you know Todd glass
on the phone you're right you're right I
didn't think about it that way I'm a
very animated person as it is god this
these two kids god help them mmm what's
gonna happen I constantly feel like I'm
messing them up and your husband's a
very mellow guy pretty mellow so but he
can get mad too yeah he gets yeah I
five-year-old is by the way I feel like
I need to asterisk such a sweetheart to
aarons met him a couple times he's had
to come and sit here on the couch yeah
because I you know couldn't find a
sitter or whatever such a sweetheart but
just by nature what a five-year-old is
he's a douche do you yell at your
husband do you raise your voice to your
husband no really no damn if we get into
an argument it's like a you know I treat
him like an audience member that is
talking back yeah I go really this is
what we're since erection you're headed
right now yeah this is what you want to
yell out right now that's how you want
to interrupt the conversation or what we
don't yell we don't yell very rarely I
can think of maybe three times oh yeah
in 13 years and the and your daughters I
just a year 14 months 14 months and
house they love making with the
husband's the fact it's not where it
used to be oh no no no nighttime or
daytime ah has to be day that's with us
we've never recovered from only day
still only guy she's still in our room
oh yeah yeah so it has to be day while
she's napping in the room no it has to
be while both kids are at grandma
grandpa's
hey yeah I know I know I do you know
them in the room I can't have them in
that no no no but that's not true when
it was just the one kid he's in his own
room yeah sure I can't do I never know
where our [ __ ] daughter likes to walk
into a room in the middle of the night I
walked in on my daughters I'm I don't
want to ever walk in on us so it's day
time on when they're at school yes yeah
but how lucky that your schedule allows
that i know i'm home i'm not home at
night anyway yeah yeah so what is your
road work like now because I feel like
the older they get do you feel less
guilty going on the road I think as long
as it's consistent like I used to have
to go on the road like wednesday and
come back on Monday and now I leave
usually on Thursday and come back on the
first flight sunday morning you and I go
maybe every other weekend so it's not
too bad where can people find you oh
Jesus and what boy you know what a lot
plug is a big benefit that I'm doing for
new school West's on Sunday night that I
know you're gonna be at yes and tickets
for that are at nsw calm and then is nsw
or just new school west calm and then
also i'm doing a benefit on October
sixteenth for the best buddies which are
mentally challenged people and that's
gonna have nuttin or mcdonalds and Joe
Rogan and Marc Maron holy sháá on that
that's a great line now be a good lineup
yeah where's that that's at the comedy
still Comedy Store October sixteenth and
otherwise just slipped fits dog radio
it's out there it's just churning along
new episodes all the time you have to a
week to a week a week every week once
last time you were on it's been a while
hasn't it I was promoting my one hour
special I was pregnant so that was a
year year-and-a-half will you come back
on as soon as possible yes would love to
have my love she did she set it up so we
could done it back to back today boom
front-to-front whatever i'm into
anything 69 a podcast yeah 69 your
podcast
thank you for not killing yourself on my
podcast oh well I feel like I feel it's
bittersweet could it now you get him
come up with a name for it yeah Greg
Fitzsimmons did not kill himself will
you name it that may be okay again then
I gotta get a graphics girl yeah such a
pain in the I know I saw the same intro
song that my kids sang when he was two
can I hear it yeah listen to the [ __ ]
podcast and then you know it's a
parenting podcast I did know that you
did I did but then I just didn't realize
that you didn't have people that were
not parents on well why would it be a
pair cuz people have opinions all right
should I have non parents haven't jen
kirkman on oh she does she does not want
kids no she doesn't want kids I get it
but she's doing half kids don't like
doing it because she feels like she's
[ __ ] up and she doesn't want to raise
a kid that's not a good kid I think he
doesn't dislike kid right right right I
get it she made that distinction to me
very clearly that makes sense yeah she's
a smart lady great career sure why [ __ ]
that ho goodbye her tits or one color I
mean her tits are amazing yeah i don't
know i'm assuming i have no idea yes you
do I off top I head I can't tell you
does she have bigger small breasts I
don't know I usually know those things
I'm really disappointed yeah all right
we're gonna go look at everybody look up
jen kirkman stands right now google
image it tagged us on facebook thanks
Greg are have you so nice I love you too
you're the best alright so that was my
my podcast with Greg one of my favorites
follow him do the things that need to
get done to go see him live whatever
needs to happen you need to get a
babysitter you need to get an extra job
you need to take care of your body hair
whatever you need to do to make you feel
good to get you out of the house to go
see him live you will not be
disappointed I'm telling you right now I
repeat you will not be disappointed one
of my favorite comics and I'm excited to
perform with him this weekend at his
kids fundraiser
and you can check out his schedule of
course at his website Greg fits dog
radio no [ __ ] what's your website just
Greg Fitzsimmons greg fitzsimmons and go
check us out my website Kira comedy calm
and of course follow at all things
comedy on the twitter at kira comedy on
the twitter at hilarious you can figure
out how to spell it there's like 3 h's
know i love errands so much so much i
can't tell you i feel it you feel it um
follow everybody just follow everyone
and give us stars and go to iTunes and
do all the things be a good person
alright be a good person will talk to
you next time bye